[Music]
what i do have is i have a uh
very awkward moment when brendan chobb
appeared on logan paul's podcast give me
the wwb
oh it's worse than that brandon shop
showed up with his own stuff to plug
brendan straub is joining us today
how are you brandon i'm good
good man how you fellas doing
okay can we talk about before we even
press play just a little bit
what is the the shoe thing with this guy
what what's what's what's going on here
oh um
he's a clown oh he's a clown [ __ ]
clown he's doing clown things like shoes
they're going for shoes
are you dipping around yeah yeah yeah
dude
what
well not not tobacco though
nicotine that's what
is that was that a sponsor
and they
they
covered up with their sponsor which is
that prime energy drink or whatever that
they have
that's funny man it gets better
yeah
but it started off naturally though i've
been with him like i've been using it
for three years are we
you know what he's about to ask
are we getting paid
are you getting paid free i mean you can
have something well i should
i mean by the way i hate all of these
people they're all hateable people of
course
but
this is funny man
i should say why you're on well a like
you're on the show because you have a
special coming out correct that i want
to talk thursday
this thursday uh
next week uh next week thursday okay so
this will be coming on twitter oh
awesome where is it coming out uh
youtube
also can i just say something i like the
look with the dip in his mouth
he's wait it's way too much dip too
right way too much you notice that
nobody respects him no he's doing these
things because friends of friends and a
lot of people have the same managers
look man just let him in just do a quick
thing yeah ten minutes he's just to plug
your [ __ ] yeah
just i do youtube
yeah you
you are you a vlogger
they don't even know who he is
they don't even know who he is
they don't even know who he is
logan paul
doesn't even know who brendan schaub is
he's like thanos i don't even know who
you are do you know
how [ __ ] pissed he must have been
when he left there are you like
a vlogger
do youtube
also youtube sorry but go back but i
just
he's got too much dip in his mouth
also putting dip in um your mouth in
somebody's studio is gross
and then also first you already have a
speech impediment and cte
why are you putting things in your mouth
while you're on the air why don't you
inject some novocaine while you're at it
yeah why are you coming with cotton from
the doctor's office stuffed in the back
i mean just like you already sound like
a mumbling [ __ ] maybe you don't put
dip in your mouth
you're you do are you a vlogger no not
at all
no
i'm so uncomfortable
ask me ask me if i'm a vlogger are you a
vlogger no i actually do more of sort of
a talk show oriented format uh with my
partner royce lopez
you see how easy that was yeah but you
don't have a mouth full of dip so am i
supposed to understand you no
you do youtube
what is this are they [ __ ] with him
this
i'm very uncomfortable are they [ __ ]
with him
either they're [ __ ] with him or his
boy is like
and this is another theory i might have
just taken a bunch of mushrooms yeah
drink something yeah because that that
would be that's i'm getting that vibe
too like logan paul
micro dust but the other guy just ate
like a whole athlete yeah
the guy who looks like [ __ ] just
incredible yeah
you're doing great
i made my nickname stick boy big boy
yeah
so many c's
and we did jiu jitsu classes together
and um i don't know you do jujitsu yeah
oh yeah for all them i can roll bro
i can roll a couple years all right yeah
carry on does wifey handle the super
strict she's latin runs it like [ __ ]
stone
same with you
we got to go to dinner wait right now
a 42 minute boy yeah i think they're on
drugs i think i think you i think you
actually nailed it
i think one of them did too much drugs
yeah i don't think they're just
intentionally [ __ ] with brandon's job
i think they're high i think they're
high i mean look at his pupils i think
you might be right i think logan paul's
on a respectable amount of drugs and i
think the friend just was like logan
paul's on i could go out i'm out of
drugs and the friend's like i shouldn't
leave the house that's why he's like
weird go out no
uber eats right
always the only episode
is that how long
we got to go to dinner bro yeah sorry
guys
well
that was awkward
dude i want to see this whole thing it's
i bet it's so
what is what was that what did i just
watch
so we know i didn't even watch that i
experienced that that was
i i mean this is before the special so
we must have missed this
i'm ruining the vibes and the girls like
i want to stay with you like a
sweetheart we get in the van we're on
our way home
and out of
nowhere dude
i threw up in the van
all over i threw up in the van next to a
goddess frat boy stupid stories
uh
let's let's see logan's fancy style
let's see what are we coachella lovers
most replayed most replays we want right
yeah
i'll tell you about coachella
i
i can normally handle my alcohol i'm
pretty good and i can drink a lot
and so they're
so i was stupid
i was drinking a lot and at coachella
you're always running around it's hot in
that size marathon you're not drinking
water worse you're not eating so when
you're not eating and you are drinking
not water alcohol it could lead to some
bad things i'm i'm
what is this it's i'm sorry why is this
the most replayed [ __ ]
way he said no way this kid is a savage
savage night girl
if it is true my man you threw up on
somebody still had sex you won you can't
you can't
i hate this
i don't want to be around anymore it's
this phony just
boys
oh god
and shot at somebody four times
everybody grazed his hand and terrible
shot yeah four times hit him once and
that's my take away from it yeah that
shot that shot
why are why are all these people uh
doing all that stuff
you know i mean if you're asap rocky
remember he was in
sweden sweden
brennan has a really tough times when he
leaves the confines of the fighter and
the kids oh he's absolutely not yeah
whenever he's not
insulated whenever he doesn't have a
brian calendar like a theo vaughn kind
of he needs to be protected
he exposes himself when he's buying
himself like he he can't play away games
yeah
you know what i mean he's yeah he's a qb
that just sucks on the road oh man
[ __ ] ryan lee mom jeans over here
good kid stop what are you serious
caitlyn
that's impressive yeah of course you get
brownie points no but if they were this
is this is a great thing you're not
gonna you don't you don't care about
what the fact that she just [ __ ] us
like that and like told us one thing and
then went back
people like this huh i don't know what
this is they got our dunkaroos i guess
i mean dunkaroos are tight i mean i
guess that should be the most watched
part
engagement is a beast for him because
when you talk
this is what i heard he said i can't
quote this but
before our regular conversations for him
to break it down that's why ants are so
slow he says it's like him it's like a
regular person talking to a
four-year-old
is he talking about himself
are you the four-year-old also
is it a four-year-old a regular person i
mean he doesn't know
he's stupid the four-year-old's like a
regular person right does that look like
the ears of a smart man
no
no
and that's forever man so he's like so
if if you were talking a four-year-old
you know you like if you're like yo dad
what's a car yeah you're breaking some
[ __ ] down that's how his daily
interaction with anybody yeah engineers
at [ __ ] spacex wow and they'll have a
problem they said he'll come in like and
they've been working on it for months
come like no no literally we'll stare
and go do this this this and they're
like [ __ ] dude
he's worked on this for months he's that
smart he's a monster oh my god he's also
funny he's you know he's basically he
knows elon musk apparently is this what
he's doing is that what he's doing i
think he's talking about elon musk but
like what is he are you friends with him
too like pete davidson
all right man look i i i'm done with
this i it's as much as i could stand i
can only do like a infinite amount of of
these guys every show because
they're just so uninteresting and then
you just want to kill yourself yeah
because they're just they're so
uninteresting you know